foreign
if I were to ask you to name the
greatest example of political courage in
modern American history I'm sure many
possibilities Will Spring immediately to
mind we are blessed to be led by a
collection of the bravest and most
inspirational human beings to have ever
lived on the planet I think we all agree
with that courage is their defining
feature indeed if Washington DC is known
for anything it is known as a place of
High character and moral fortitude and
so if you wanted to name the all-time
greatest example of Courage among our
elected officials we'd have a tough time
picking just one but you might point to
the time when Alexandra Casio Cortez
went to the border and bravely faced
down an empty parking lot and wept
theatrically while the cameraman she
brought with her took pictures
or you might mention the time when
Congressional Democrats donned African
tribal Garb and knelt on one knee in
honor of Saint George Floyd what about
the the time when Congressman Andy Kim
announced that he was donating the blue
suit that he wore on January 6 to the
Smithsonian so that the Day quote will
never be forgotten
of course not all the most valuable
Valiant moments have come courtesy of
Democrats Republicans are also famously
bold and Intrepid remember for example
when some Dr Seuss books were getting
canceled so Kevin McCarthy recorded a
video of himself reading Green Eggs and
Ham even though that wasn't one of the
canceled books these and many other acts
of heroism come to mind but all of them
pale in comparison to this
representative Greg kassar a democrat in
Texas
stood in front of the U.S capitalist
week to protest a law in Texas that
supposedly eliminates heat protections
and water breaks for workers in the
state
now we haven't gotten to the really
courageous part yet but first let's hear
a bit of Greg kassar delivering his
Brave speech a couple of days ago listen
this month in the hottest month
Texas history and many of our cities on
July 4th it was the hottest day in
recorded world history supposed leaders
entrusted by us to do about right by us
by Governor Greg Abbott
stripped workers right to a water break
away
[Music]
that ain't right he does that because it
is Big corporate interest top priority
and so it is his priority
but what they're not counting on is that
they're not going to stop us
that if we work and we advance forward
that if they shut that down that they
shut us down and today we're here to
show that they will never shut down the
movements of workers that movement of
women the movement of young people and
intergenerational years our hearts and
our faith and democracy cannot be
stopped we are joined by people from
across the country and I feel an
overwhelming sense of hope I know
there's people out there working in 110
degrees today and my sense is it's my
job to do out here and do my job
and my sense is it's my job to do out
here and do my job
I can only assume that was a Joe Biden
quote and quite an eloquent one but
kassar's point is that it's hot outside
and people need water breaks and Greg
Abbott's law outlawing water breaks his
law which says that workers cannot have
water
is an atrocity and the media needless to
say agrees which is why there have been
many headlines calling attention to this
travesty the guardian reports quote
Texas governor signs Bill rescinding
water breaks as deadly heat grips State
NBC News declares backlash Brews against
Texas law that eliminates mandatory
water breaks Business Insider Texas
construction workers protest after Greg
Abbott axed mandated water breaks
calling it the law that kills you get
the idea
the only problem with all of this and
it's it's a minor problem really I mean
a technically
is that it's all completely made up
Texas is not eliminating water breaks
there's no law being signed by Abbott
that rescinds water breaks or even
addresses the issue of water breaks okay
Greg Abbott is not some sort of super
villain who's sitting there and he sees
that it's hot outside he says you know
what I'm going to do I'm going to take
away their water no more water for any
of you
your pansies you don't need water
no one's allowed to have water
that didn't happen Okay the New York
Times article on this controversy admits
this 10 paragraphs down it stipulates
the law does not address water breaks or
other specific ordinances instead it
bans action by cities to regulate work
conditions that go beyond state law
Texas law does not provide for water
breaks according to the federal
occupational safety and health
administration neither does federal law
so in other words this is all over a law
by the state it was passed by uh by by
state legislators that attempts to
address inconsistencies and policies and
regulations and ensure that local
policies don't conflict with State
policy and Texas has decided that this
is necessary because Progressive blue
cities in Texas often attempt to do
things and pass ordinances and
regulations that directly conflict with
state law
but none of this has anything to do with
water breaks
the legislation again says nothing about
water breaks Democrats simply went
looking for the most outrageous possible
hypothetical consequence of this action
by Abbott and they came up with this
idea that it might mean that
construction workers can't drink water
but of course this law by no means
prevents anyone from taking a water
break or means that anyone's not going
to have it it does not rescind water
breaks or ban them or take them away
there is no evidence that any
construction worker in the State
anywhere will now be forced to go
without water this is completely made up
for the record if you're hiring you're
probably dealing with economic
uncertainty and now more than ever it's
important to hire the right people
faster and more efficiently to keep
overall costs down thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner who is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
smart technology identifies the best
matches for your job and lets you invite
candidates who really want to apply who
you really want to apply for your job
before other businesses can snag them up
I love how their pricing is really
straightforward you know what you pay
before posting your job so you can stick
to your budget with no surprises hire
the best with the help of a partner
who's all about you with zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post a
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within day one just go to this exclusive
web address to try ZipRecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com Walsh again that's
ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
now as we get deeper into the summer uh
it's all the more important to think
about ways that you can maintain a
healthy lifestyle even if you're very
busy and one of the ways you can do that
is by eating lots of fruits and
vegetables they're a great way to make
sure that you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
through balance of Nature's Advanced
cold vacuum process the vitamins
minerals and phytonutrients of the
fruits and vegetables are preserved so
you can get that vital nutrition in each
capsule balance of nature is a whole
food supplement with no additives no
fillers no extracts no synthetics no
pesticides or added sugar pure fruits
and vegetables are the only things they
put in their capsule it's as simple as
that balance of nature send a bunch of
their products down to the studio for my
team to try we all love them when you're
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all the kinds of
benefits that are available to your your
body will thank you for it for a limited
time this summer when you become a
preferred customer a balance of nature
they're throwing in a free fruits and
vegetables travel set and giving an
additional 25 off your first order go to
bounce of nature.com use promo code
Wells for a free travel set and 25
dollars off your first order as a
preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code Walsh but
let's not allow that to distract us from
the heroism
the fact that none of this is true and
it's all completely bogus doesn't mean
that we can't be inspired by it
especially considering this detail
representative Greg kassar didn't just
stand there and protest a law that
doesn't exist he protested the invisible
law while not eating or drinking kasar
in solidarity with the workers who can
all definitely still drink water decided
to go on a thirst and hunger strike he
announced that he would not eat or drink
water for as long as possible he would
sit on the steps he would eat nothing he
would drink nothing
for an unspecified amount of time
and that is what this Brave man did
over time his movement grew one by one
other elected Democrats showed up and
joined the hunger and thirst strike by
not eating or drinking for at least the
amount of time it took them to give a
three-minute speech Joaquin Castro
posted his speech along with a black and
white photo trying to make it look like
some kind of great historic moment in
the fight for civil rights and it was
because of all the fictional laws that
have ever not existed the fictional law
that doesn't ban construction workers
from drinking water is certainly among
the worst
and Castro made that clear listen
Texas Republicans for years have talked
about the Texas miracle these are the
people that built the Texas Miracle yeah
the people that when you're driving
along in 105 degree weather out on the
highway they're working out on the
highway on I-35 the people that are
working on top of roofs in San Antonio
in the Rio Grande Valley in Fort Worth
all over the state the people that are
working in fields picking crops they
built the Texas Miracle not Greg Abbott
yeah that's right and I challenge the
governor to spend one day
one day without water
one day in the governor's mansion the
air-conditioned governor's mansion
without water
yes can the governor go one day without
water
representative casar is doing it maybe
well it was still unclear how long his
strike was going to last but in the
meantime many other Democrats stopped by
representative Hakeem Jeffrey is
representative Sylvia Garcia
representative pramila jayapal tweeted
her support she said thank you
representative casar for standing up for
workers and showing the stunning cruelty
of taking away even heat and water
breaks looking forward to coming to
support you and our workers
yes it would indeed be stunning cruelty
to take away water breaks if anyone had
actually done that which nobody had but
that's not the point
you already know that AOC would not be
able to stay away from a stunt like this
and she didn't so sometime during the
course of the afternoon she showed up
briefly took some pictures and then
tweeted this we joined representative
casar and Dolores Huerta at The Thirst
strike Texas just passed a law blocking
water breaks for construction workers
President Biden can stop it by
implementing a heat stress rule it's
time for the president to act hashtag
workers can't wait
again Texas did not pass that law it
doesn't exist but whatever do not get
sidetracked by the sheer dishonesty of
all this Focus instead on the Courage
the unprecedented
undaunted courage
encourage that you cannot help but stand
and applaud especially when you hear
this part
get ready for this
when all was said and done
casar's hunger and thirst strike lasted
get this almost to nine hours
the man went almost nine hours without
food or water he made it roughly the
time from an early lunch to a late
dinner
he did what nearly everyone in the world
does every single night when they sleep
The Bravery here is simply impossible to
fully comprehend
at the end of this harrowing day kasar
tweeted quote yesterday was incredible I
was honored to be joined at my thirst
strike by workers in Texas and across
the nation and by lots of colleagues
pushing for federal heat safety
protections uh nine hours without water
or food but I'm more energized than ever
to get this done
nine hours
almost nine hours we'll call it nine
hours nine hours without water or food
I've never done anything like that in my
life
except for every time I skip lunch on a
work day which is like probably two or
three times a week so aside from two or
three times a week I've never done
anything like that I've never done
anything like that on the days when I
don't do that
we'll put it that way the point is Greg
kassar has done the unimaginable he
stopped eating and drinking around 9am
and then he had some water around 5 30
or so and went home truly a saga that
will be remembered for Generations
along with that tweet kassar posted
three photos and one of the photos is
him giving his triumphant speech where
he decries a law that doesn't exist and
one of the one of the photos was him
walking alongside Bernie Sanders who at
least has the Perpetual look of a
fatally dehydrated man and another as
was of him being attended to by three
people while they take his pulse and put
an ice pack on his neck because he
skipped lunch
this is a picture that he chose to post
himself
he wanted everyone to see that
he wanted everyone to see that this is
what he looks like after a few hours
without food or water he's like my
six-year-old when he you know asks for a
graham cracker and I tell him that we're
not we're not having snacks because
we're about to have dinner and he
collapses on the ground and cries out
that he'll surely starve
Dramatics very similar to what we're
seeing from Greg cassar which only tells
me that my six-year-old must also be a
civil rights hero
but let's not change the subject from
Greg cassar he certainly doesn't want us
to Greg kasar
The Man Who Went half a day
well like a third of a day maybe but
anyway without food or water Greg kassar
the man who nearly starved himself in
protest of a law that doesn't exist Greg
kassar
the hero who sat on the steps for a few
hours without so much as a single
Lacroix sparkling water to sustain him
his is a name
that will ring down through the
generations
his bravery will inspire Millions for
years to come
they will build statues to remember this
man
and this pivotal moment in history
when everything changed
it'll likely take him
weeks to recover from the deprivations
he suffered through
he may never be the same again
you know something that is true for the
world too we have looked upon Greg kasar
and is almost nine hours without water
or snacks
and we have been transformed by it
we stand in awe
tears in our eyes
wondering how he did it
but grateful that he did
and that is why Greg kasar is certainly
not canceled but the other Greg Greg
Abbott the governor who signed that
terrible law that also happens to be
imaginary and totally made up
is the one who is today
canceled if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed